i remember the phrase live within your
means what it's not is it's not hanging
on a poster in any kid's bedroom
anywhere yeah like i don't go to bed at
night like it's a nine-year-old going
i'm gonna live within my means
the irony inside that is the best way to
actually ultimately expand your means
over time so your means get greater and
greater is to do exactly that like
that's that's the trick to it is
is the the dissatisfaction of the
reality is something people overlook and
if you fast forward the kid if there was
a kid that had a poster on their wall
that said live within your means and
therefore they're saving and they're
putting together and you look at them in
20 years and they're in a way better
position than someone that was like
you need the lambo
or whatever right because they're going
to end up in debt yeah and they can't
invest properly and they have to work a
job that they don't really like and it's
a job that's a dead end like all these
things add up